okay day 259 of Putin's 10-day special
military operation to try and capture
Ukraine and there's just been a
significant announcement where
um the Russian defense minister has said
the Russians are going to pull their
troops back from the western side of the
danipro river now that's significant
they're pulling it out of the kherson
region an area that Vladimir Putin
declared as part of Russia um only a few
weeks ago
um and Harrison was the first city that
the Russians had captured on the 27th of
February this year
um from a political perspective this is
a massive blow for Vladimir Putin from a
military perspective the Russians will
only be doing this because they need to
withdraw the troops they can't resupply
them which is the excuse that was used
whenever they move back across the river
and looking at in a little bit more
detail we see that the river itself is a
significant obstacle it's about a
kilometer wide in some of its uh
shallower areas and the bridges have
been dropped by the ukrainians the
Russians are relying on
um uh ferries and Barge Bridges to get
their troops out but they're putting
their defenses on the Eastern side in
two or three layers and they want to
hold that through the winter to stop the
ukrainians getting forward the
ukrainians can move forward with their
artillery and their High Mars and still
have an influence on what's going on the
political significance of this cannot be
underestimated the military significance
of what the Russians are doing it could
turn into a route it's a complex
operation and they're not good at those
is significant
um and I think Vladimir Putin will be
sitting hoping that this is the last
major blow that he's going to suffer
this year however the ukrainians are
dictating the pace of whether that will
actually happen or not